so today we have the pleasure of hearing
from justice mariano florentino whaler
tino is a professor in the law school at
stanford he's also a justice on the
california supreme court he was also an
official in the clinton and obama
administration which is incredibly cool
tino did his undergrad at harvard he did
his law school at yale he also has a phd
in political science at stanford and he
has done a lot of work around cyber law
and actually like ai and legislation as
well as other work around international
affairs and public health he also
teaches a class on regulating ai which
is a very cool class so if you're
interested in these areas and if you're
interested in these topics i absolutely
recommend taking that class especially
after taking 221 i think that would be a
really good class to take
um and then we've been basically
interacting with tino through the ai
safety center and the human center the
ai institute institute over the past
couple of years we have a project
together right now on adaptive agents so
it's really great to work with tino it's
really great to hear from him and and
for me he's like on the list of the top
five people i would want to have a
conversation with this includes
roboticists this is a very small list so
it's really great today to hear from
tino and and i'm excited to hear your
talking you know so welcome
thank you very much professor sally
dorsa and thank you
percy and peng and woody it's really an
honor to be here and to share some time
with you i have to tell you that that
last comment you made dorsa is a lot of
pressure i don't want to let the class
down
and get demoted and not be on your top
five list um
it's also you know been really great to
get to know you and i learned so much
from all of our interactions i
appreciate that you've come to speak at
my class so it's only fair and it's
really an honor to be here
i want to take like 35 to 40 minutes
which i know in the era of zoom is a
long time so i'm going to hope that
those of you who have been
good enough to tune in i know these uh
doing this live is optional that you're
going to find this worthwhile i want us
to have a lot of time for this
discussion but let me just give you a
quick overview of what i mostly want to
do
i
want to explore with you why
your interest in artificial intelligence
which is what led you to take this class
is actually incredibly relevant to
policy to politics and law and along the
way you're going to see it's also
relevant to international affairs and
geopolitics
but really in the course of this talk i
want to share with you
some reasons not only why you should be
interested in law and policy and take
your technical knowledge and expect that
it's going to be relevant to a lot of
really important questions the world is
facing i also want to maybe
give you a sense of how i became really
interested in the subject along the way
and i'm going to try to share my slides
now so you have a better sense
of what we're talking about
so let me start by by noting that
right now you're at an amazing moment in
your life you're learning about
artificial intelligence you have this
extraordinary university at least
virtually around you eventually you'll
be back here physically i hope and
expect
and you can look at this talk and think
about it from the perspective of a
technical expert which is what you're
becoming by taking this class
but before we get to that i want you to
imagine yourself not as a technical
expert but to think of yourself as just
a citizen somebody who has to think
about
how does this technology affect daily
life
who's being affected by it
where are the inequities what are the
opportunities for understanding it
better
and then near the end of the talk i want
you to imagine yourself as a policy
maker somebody who has to make decisions
about how to allocate scarce resources
where government budget should go
what people should do in the legislature
and the courts
around how to resolve the technical
questions and policy questions and the
legal questions that arise
and what you're going to find is that
your technical knowledge is extremely
relevant to a lot of these crucial
issues but at the same time
you need to round out that knowledge by
understanding a little bit about the
legal system and about organizations
so
the bottom line really is that i'm going
to share with you
a lot of different messages but the core
message is that this technology that you
were learning to master has not only
benefits but risks
and in the course of
implementing that technology society is
going to be
shaping how that technology is used
through the legal system and also
through organizations through the
associations the institutions the groups
but especially the firms the agencies
that so many of us are going to work in
law firms government agencies
big corporations nonprofit organizations
now i want to tell you because i know
that it is difficult to hang on to your
attention but i'm going to try
that there are some things that i
absolutely want to remember have you
remember
if you remember one thing about my whole
presentation
it's that the impact of artificial
intelligence on the world on your daily
life is a function of law and
organizations it's not anything that
actually acts directly by itself but it
has to be mediated by some organization
by like what stanford does or what
the you know republican party does or
what
the united nations does
but also it's needed by legal rules and
along the way you're going to find that
we might sometimes talk as though we're
discussing the possibility of developing
legal rules that will apply to ai well
i'm here to suggest you that many of
those rules already exist the question
is just how to translate them to this
context
if i can convince you to remember two
things and not just one
i'd like you to remember the point above
but then also i want you to remember
some crucial terminology and that is the
techniques of ai like machine learning
are different from ai systems or
applications and these are the
mechanisms obviously that instantiate
the techniques that are attached to a
user interface i'll say more about this
later and that actually spit out
information
recommendations
insights that people will then act on
and if miraculously enough i can get you
to remember three things and this is the
last thing i really want you to remember
for sure it's the previous two points
plus that
point that law is kind of merging with
the design and policy challenges that
are implicit in ai so what i'm going to
end up is by telling you that lawyers
are becoming more and more a little bit
like people like you
who are
trying to wrap their minds around
machine learning supervised learning
unsupervised learning reinforcement
learning and in the same way
you and your community the people who
are the technical experts are
increasingly pushing to ask questions
like what is the right way to use this
technology what do we want it to do and
not do
so with that as background
let me acknowledge
more explicitly the benefits side of the
ai technology you're learning to master
because if we don't then we're going to
get a pretty distorted picture
if you were physically on campus right
now and you were walking around stanford
you could go to 10 different places on
campus where really cool stuff is
happening that is relevant to real
problems that people are facing around
the world and where ai techniques are
being used to try to make the world a
little bit of a better place
so let's take for example
the population of the world that is
facing
serious nutritional stress meaning
people who are at serious risk of
starving
a generation ago that population was
much bigger than it is now but sadly
that population is still stubbornly
large
700 million people are so faced serious
food insecurity these are generally the
people living on a dollar a day or less
you see some of the kids here
overwhelmingly that population is
concentrated in africa and in
india and in asia
but there are also some people in north
america and europe even who face food
insecurity
the different ways that we have to
allocate resources effectively to make
sure food doesn't go to waste to make
supply chains more efficient to pinpoint
where there are problems in real time
and what's more a lot of this population
not only faces problems around food but
also faces problems around education
the distribution of access to high
quality education is incredibly unequal
as you know we're all a part of that
system we take part in it
so
when i think about the future of both
nutrition and education
in a world that is more equitable and
more benign i cannot imagine that future
without some use of artificial
intelligence techniques to democratize
education to make the delivery of food
more efficient to pinpoint problems in
real time
in somewhat similar fashion this uh
quirky uh set of four images you see
here is an example of the work that dan
hoe my colleague at the law school is
doing with some colleagues
to use satellite imagery to pinpoint
where sources of pollution are
in
much more accurate fashion than anything
the government currently has really and
what that would allow us to do is more
effectively
cross-reference the self-reported data
that comes from firms that claim to be
complying with environmental law with
the reality and it takes some
fairly sophisticated but also in some
ways intuitive machine learning
techniques to make use of this visual
data
and then you've got a picture of a
courtroom
this is not the kind of courtroom where
i sit because it's the trial courtroom
mostly this is where trials are actually
heard in superior court
the reality is that in california if we
had more time and if we were in person i
would ask you to guess the number of
cases
we
hear in california courts every year
and generally speaking when i ask that
question people like 20 000 and i give a
shock response that's too long people
say okay
200 000 and my eyebrows still go up and
finally we'll get to like 800 000 well
the actual retail answer is like 6
million cases a year
so it will not shock you to hear that
probably 40 50
of those cases the litigants are
self-represented there are people like
you
they don't have a lawyer
they
are trying their best to navigate an
incredibly complicated system i would
love to imagine a world where the
distribution of legal knowledge is not
so restricted just to people who have a
stanford law degree or a similarly great
credential or can pay a lot of money for
a fancy lawyer but where software and ai
systems that you might help design can
help people navigate a very intricate
legal system
but at the very far right you see a
picture of an african-american man under
the words criminal of justice and
there's a question mark there
and
why i'm doing that is to highlight that
this whole world we can imagine also has
its risks and its downsides and to make
this more concrete i want to focus on
one person in particular
the gentleman you see here robert
williams is one of
many people whose lives are being
affected by the fact that artificial
intelligence systems are not just
theoretical anymore in terms of their
practical application
they're being used
in all kinds of settings including in
the criminal justice system
so here he was one day in a suburb of
detroit when he gets arrested by police
he's told that he's being arrested
because he's suspected of committing
larceny which is a fancy word for
stealing
robbing a store
in detroit and it turns out that because
the police were using an image
recognition system doing facial
recognition
and they had a
base of data corpus of 49 million images
and the system indicated that the image
from the security camera in detroit
matched robert williams's picture
he was arrested
now you might ask did the police have
another reason to suspect him did were
there outstanding arrest warrants for
him had he committed similar crimes in
the past and the answer is no no no okay
so once he was arrested the police
admitted that the photo is a little
blurry
they admitted that they didn't have any
other information about him and after a
little bit more
discussion
they ultimately
agreed with mr williams that the picture
really just didn't look like him meaning
the intuitive human response was like no
that doesn't seem to be you but the
algorithm says it's you so what do we do
the answer is he was detained for 30
hours
now
i'm not suggesting that there aren't
worse things than being detained for no
reason for 30 hours
but i'll tell you i grew up on the u.s
mexico border and it was a fact of life
in my family that sometimes you need to
cross over to the american side to go
shopping or do something else like that
and
being detained even 45 minutes an hour
an hour and 15 minutes all those things
happen to me it's not very pleasant so
you can imagine what it's like or you
can begin to imagine if you tried what
it's like to be detained more than 38
hours and they'll be told that it's
because a computer made a mistake
computer must have gotten it wrong was
the exact thing that he was told
everything that i want to share with you
from here on out in a way you could sum
up by asking this narrow question of why
did this happen to mr williams and what
does that mean what are the remedies do
we have a legal system a society where
we can sort of disentangle the mistaken
uses from the correct ones manage the
risks appropriately can we take
seriously the fact that humans also make
mistakes when they're looking for faces
i'll say more about that in a moment
but i hope i can press you to think
about the situation with mr williams in
a little bit of a broader context
because
we could talk about criminal justice or
we could talk about testing
as you may know the intellectual the
international baccalaureate exams this
last year because of code were not
actually given but instead students were
given a score that was their predicted
score based on the previous portfolio
work they'd submitted we can talk about
testing uh
in remote settings where your facial
your image is sort of being analyzed by
a camera that's trying to detect whether
you're cheating
we can talk about insurance we can talk
about it
36 other domains where this stuff is
really effective life and the broader
question really is
what does the incident involving robert
williams tell us about law
about artificial intelligence and about
how society is changing
and our legal system is changing in
response to this technology
so that is the tip of a very very big
iceberg now let me acknowledge again
the point about how
there's a lot about this subject that
goes deeper it doesn't just start with
the history of artificial intelligence
it actually starts with the history of
really modern society
now on the screen you see the picture of
a very intense looking man
named
max weber
for anybody who's ever taken a class on
social theory or sociology his name
might be familiar
there's a lot i could say about him but
here's the main point i want to make
writing
in the very early 20th century max weber
was looking around society and observing
things noting
society didn't work the same way
then that it did 100 or 200 years ago
many many people worked inside
organizations with a hierarchy
formal systems of authority
organizations had a director an
assistant director officials clerks
and all of this observed max labor was a
means to which the modern nation state
processed information
took it and decided what to do with it
rationally sometimes developing the
mechanisms to act as if by reflex by
recognizing the kind of problem and
quickly delivering a response sometimes
by elevating it to people who could sit
in an office talk in a conference room
and come up with a solution thinking
presumably logically and what max faber
noted much to the influence of people
who came after him including yours truly
is that these bureaucracies aspired to
work like a machine right they were
trying to automate the process of
decision-making in some way to the point
that it could be predictable and
rational and
weber pointed out that that was all well
and good but there were going to be some
problems along the way and in some ways
i'm here to tell you that many of the
problems that weber highlighted how we
have a love-hate relationship with these
bureaucracies on the one hand we think
that they're inefficient that they're
rule-bound that they're not creative
that they're frustrating that they're
slow but at the same time we can't live
without them
that will end up illuminating in some
ways
some of the really interesting choices
we have about how we use artificial
intelligence maybe in some ways to
replace conventional bureaucracy but i
would argue in other ways
to replicate and in some ways channel
some of the same
tragic conflicts and tensions
now
channeling max weber to some degree and
also reflecting my own interest in ai in
2016 i wrote a piece
that had the following punchline
basically which was
sometimes we're going to deal with the
concerns we have about the role of
artificial intelligence by suggesting
that really all we're building are
recommendation engines not really that
different from the way netflix works you
may also like to watch this
judge you may think that this person
deserves a harsher sentence but it's
really up to you judge you don't have to
be the one to decide or rather you don't
you have to be the one to decide we
don't have to be the ones to decide we
the ones who designed the ai system
we're just giving you a recommendation
we're using these techniques to give you
a sense of what the likelihood is this
person will be offended
and the point i was trying to make in
2016 which seems now like a long time
ago
is that actually
that line between the computer program
in particular the ai system that has
sophisticated user interface capacities
to sort of speak to you in natural
language or to serve up the information
in a way that's easier for you to
assimilate it's really difficult to
police that line between they're just
supporting your decision and they're
actually making the decision
now here's one place where i can
highlight my point at the very beginning
about how
law emerges with organizations which
merges with ai if you really want to
understand the effect right so if you
want to know if an ai system is actually
serving as a decision support tool
rather than actually making a decision
you're going to want to know the answer
to questions like well
are the designers of that system liable
if it turns out to make a recommendation
that's really really bad that results in
people getting injured
or conversely is the organization run in
a way that the decision making the
decision maker using the ai system
is being audited and is being checked to
see if all of her decisions are just
exactly rubber stamping what the
software does and if that's the case
what's the point of having the human
decision making in the loop anyway right
so i'm giving you the sense that we're
building up to this point of all these
conflicts and questions and meanwhile
people like robert williams are getting
arrested
but now let me return to this point
about how
humans often are not great decision
makers too
so we can think about where it is that
human cognition
fails in terms of perception
we can think about how humans add up
information and come up with a thought
or a decision we can think about what
motivates humans whether it is that even
if i have every reason in the world
based on my job to be fair when i'm
working in a police station i'm deciding
who to arrest if i have an improper
motivation if i want to impress somebody
who happens to be on a ride-along with
me that day or if i really dislike the
person who works in this particular area
of town and i want to arrest them
because i have a nefarious motivation
that can mean that human decision making
gets all messed up and even the legal
arrangements we have to police human
behavior
can fall short
but my next slide which is probably the
messiest slide of the whole presentation
so you don't have to memorize it or even
read it all
you know i can make these available to
you later but here's the punchline the
punchline is that the mere argument that
humans are not as good as the
performance of ai systems in a discrete
test like facial recognition does not
really answer the question of how you
want
ai systems to be used by organizations
to make decisions because the devil's
really in the details let me just pick
two points here to highlight
let's talk about perception
so the field of
the neurophysiology of how vision works
is really really complicated and
fascinating and it's not an accident i
would argue that some of the coolest
things that we have been learning
about
how to develop better image recognition
systems in the ii space are influenced
by what we learned from neuroscience
but the fact that that's still a bit of
a mystery highlights to you that
we actually
only understand a little bit about how
humans make visual processing decisions
for example we know that it takes about
100 milliseconds for humans to perceive
whether a picture reflects a person of
one gender or another generally for
humans to pick up emotions for humans to
recognize familiar faces but eyewitness
identification i do you remember that
involves unfamiliar faces do you
remember whether this image is showing
you the person that you
think you saw two weeks ago when the
glass was shattered and somebody came
into your apartment at night and grabbed
your beautiful collection of baseball
cards and left
that is a lot less exact and as one of
my colleagues explained in a dissenting
opinion in a case called people we read
you know
we would be
grossly inaccurate if we suggested that
that is a
system of identification that works
really really well
but then of course if you compare that
to the way ai systems work on the one
hand ai systems might be
in the lab much more accurate than
humans at picking out the similarity
between two images
just at random not that are sort of
known earlier the way humans might know
them earlier
but on the other hand the ability of
those systems outside of the lab to
operate effectively
and particularly to detect emotions for
example
is not so great
these systems have
in a number of applications and
instantiations real differences in how
effectively they work for pictures of
people who identify as white rather than
for blacks or asians and of course you
have all kinds of other failure modes
like hackie
and then of course we could talk about
legal arrangements and here i would just
note that
we humans have
hundreds of years of experience dealing
with human mistakes that's really what
the legal system is designed to do
we are only learning now how to adapt
our legal rules and standards to deal
with the mistakes that machines make
we're not starting from scratch but it
would be a mistake to assume that we
figured out exactly how to do that
so
now i want to make the point that when
we are dealing with problems posed by ai
in the legal system
we are not starting from scratch and the
best way i can make that point is to
just highlight for those of you who are
vicariously interested in asking
yourself what would it be like to go to
law school what would that feel like
and you're thinking well maybe that
would not be terrible maybe it might be
kind of fun
i'll give you a flavor of some of the
subjects that people learn about in law
school and it will not take a rocket
scientist that will not take a stanford
computer science professor to see
that these subjects that we cover in law
school they're just literally touching
right up against ai
already and it will continue to be the
case
so in an area of law called agency law
is where we figure out like if professor
sadik says to a ta i want you to go
across campus and i want you to pick up
this particular
computer and i want you to carry it to
the other side of campus and along the
way the person picks up the computer but
then gets distracted drops the computer
and kills a bird and it turns out that
that bird is the prize-winning bird of
somebody's like bird collection or
whatever
does professor sadik end up being
responsible well agency law resolves
that kind of question when are you
responsible for the actions of others in
your organization of your agent
now ordinarily agency law applies to the
actions that you begin to put in motion
that some other human being engages in
but you can totally see how this branch
of law is beginning to grapple with the
question of when you are responsible for
the actions that you set in motion
because you design an agent to do
something
like to sort employee applicants and
then the agent does that the artificial
software based agent
okay so then you have my core field of
administrative law and legislation this
is the law of what
counts as sufficient justification for
any action of government
if the president signs an executive
order saying i don't want
the census to keep on going until
december i want it to stop in october
when does the president have the power
to do that how does that power
get into some conflict potentially with
the power of congress to pass a law
saying how long the sense is supposed to
continue you get the idea what if the
government says well you're going to
have to move out of this home because we
want to build a road through here what
right do you have to challenge that kind
of action
so obviously the more and more that
government decision making
involves reliance on machines the more
and more that this branch of law is
going to have to deal with the question
of
what does it mean when the machine is
empowered to play a crucial role in that
government decision does that make it
more reliable less reliable more fair
less fair when can we do that one can we
not do that
last but certainly not least tort law
tort law is about who has a duty to whom
what counts as a reasonable decision and
how do we attribute causal
responsibility for bad things that
happen translation let's say you're back
on campus and sadly you get covert 19.
can you blame the university
when why can you blame the university
why can you not
or you know let's suppose forget covert
19 for a moment let's suppose that
you're in a lab and sadly your lab
partner
decides to try to attack you and you
survive but you're asking well wasn't
the university responsible for making
sure that i wasn't attacked that's
toward law
and you can imagine that as the
information that is the fuel of modern
ai systems and the sort of fuel for
machine learning increasingly flows to
systems that are interconnected
questions about what a decision maker
does with that information and whether
that information makes the decision
maker responsible for a different kind
of safety protection relative to
somebody that could be protected that
all becomes more interesting
okay
so let me give you some context for how
to think about these problems by just
acknowledging the history of ai is kind
of long and it does not start with the
birth of the internet it goes back
further in history to some of professor
sadik's colleagues in the computer
science department at stanford so i
could go on and on about this but my
little uh
subtext in addition to what i want to
share about the history of ai is to kind
of quickly give you a sense of how in
the world i became super interested in
this beginning a little in college but
then again when i worked in government
at the treasury department and even more
so when i came back from working for
obama in uh 2010
so
just look at those pictures for a moment
you might recognize some of these faces
i'm sure you recognize at least one
the one where the woman had read as it
were but if you go back a little further
what you're going to see in the picture
under 1950s is herbert simon
a really really smart man whose parents
were refugees from germany who spent
most of his career at carnegie mellon
university
and
i mean come on you have to be pretty
smart if you
start as a political scientist but then
become interested in psychology end up
writing about economics and winning the
nobel prize in economics and along the
way you become like a major pioneer of
ai that was herbert simon for you he was
so brilliant i recommend to you any book
or article ever written by herbert simon
among other things
one of the reasons he won the nobel
prize in economics is because he
developed the notion of bounded
rationality which is at the core of what
we call behavioral economics now the
notion that you may not
you may be best modeled as a human not
as somebody who's trying to optimize but
as somebody who's trying to satisfy a
certain threshold and we can certainly
use that insight to imagine how to
design a software agent and how to do
machine learning which is one reason why
you can imagine his expertise and
brilliance got transferred over into ai
he's most associated ai with the story
of um
development of systems to do basically
like first order logic
and mathematical type reasoning what
some refer to as good old-fashioned ai
and i'll just note here that that was
really important but always
treat it as the holy grail maybe
something was elusive and not possible
to realize the kind of instinctive
almost automatic decision making and
motion that now is so much at the
cutting edge of what we are helping
robots and ai systems to do
the recognition piece was missing even
if the cognition piece at least around
how you prove theorems was possible to
instantiate early on briefly by the
1970s the picture really is different
here that picture includes
ed fagenbaum somebody who is a colleague
in computer science and always someone
fascinating to talk to somebody who's
been one of my mentors a little bit and
trying to learn about ai and he's very
much associated with expert systems with
taking insights from not only
the work of herbert's simon who was
actually
ed fagenbaum's
but also from
psychology and sociology and decision
theory to develop systems that could act
almost as experts and replicate
knowledge in particular domains
and then by the 2000s the real
phenomenon that changes everything and
certainly gives rise to the prominence
of the person in the third picture
sheryl sandberg is the rise of the
internet because of course all this
stuff about ai was happening partly in
academic labs
and partly in defense departments
but uh suddenly the ability we have to
harvest and centralize
billions and billions and billions of
pieces of behavioral data from humans
and of course to do it in
systems that work
faster and have access to more computing
power lets us do some truly amazing
things and i'll just note here that my
interest in this begins in college in 93
when i was trying to understand how
human decision making could be modeled
so kind of very much the herbert simon
sort of work
but when i was working in treasury in
the late 90s
wasn't lost on me that there was just so
much
data that the us government had gathered
around financial transactions and i was
interested in privacy as you might have
been but also interested in the idea
that if that data were available how
could it be used in a way that was
efficient lawful
analytically sophisticated to detect
really really problematic
uses of the financial system including
to commit corruption for example to
launder money and so on
and so i became exposed to some of the
techniques that you're learning about in
this class right now
when i came back from the obama
administration in 2010 it struck me that
so many of the domains in which i was
working particularly around public
health and criminal justice
were already being affected by early
examples and applications of this stuff
so i became really interested in trying
to understand how this stuff would
affect
every aspect of decision making in law
and political science and try to learn
more about what you're learning about
right now
so here's where i want to highlight
where my own thinking went after i
returned from the white house in 2010
it struck me that some of the most
interesting work happening in ai in
universities but also in the private
sector was about pushing the boundaries
of analytical techniques to discern
patterns
unsupervised learning reinforcement
learning and so on and the breakthroughs
were really extraordinary and they
continue to be
but it was also striking to me that
these techniques in their raw form were
not necessarily designed to influence or
help non-experts they were not
necessarily designed to solve real-world
problems
so if instead you're looking at how ai
techniques get used
like they were used in the arrest of
robert williams you're not dealing with
ai techniques by themselves you're
dealing with ai systems
which
my co-author and i defined using
probably a little too much mumbo jumbo a
socio-technical embodiment of policy
codified an appropriate con
computational learning tool so a system
to gather data and learn from the data
and embedded in a specific institutional
context meaning it fits in an
organization and is given a certain
purview
people who make decisions are told
here's how you can use the tool here's
how you shouldn't use the tool right
and really what that means is when you
want to understand how ai is being used
in the real world
you have to understand relationships of
power who gets to decide that the system
works the way it does and that somebody
can point to that system and claim that
it embodies some kind of intelligence
why does this matter well it matters
because now here we get to the other
side of the coin of the internet right
we're not in a world where this is
mostly happening in the lab right now
we're in a world where really important
things in the world are being affected
by ai i cannot give this lecture without
pointing to the toothbrush that somebody
recently gave me as a gift that
advertises how it uses artificial
intelligence to learn how to brush your
teeth
and this is the genesis of a concept i
call toothbrush maturity
when technology gets to be so ubiquitous
to the point that it intersects even
with a toothbrush then you know that
you're dealing with something that has
to be understood in its real world
context and not just in the theoretical
stories you can tell about how well it's
going to work another example of this
really though is that
the very large internet companies that
are around us in silicon valley have a
market capitalization that you can't
really explain without understanding
just how well online advertising must be
working and how much it's leveraging the
enormous amounts of data that are
generated by the internet and analyzed
by some of the ai techniques that you
are learning about here where's this
going is so interesting and the short
answer is i really wonder whether anyone
really fully knows
and that's true of almost any technology
right you can't always predict by the
way i'm about three quarters of the way
through the presentation so just bear
with me for a few more minutes but
you know i can point to the different
things here but the main point i want
this slide to highlight for you is that
some of the breakthroughs that we're
seeing right now are not so much
progress in terms of just more clever
algorithms or even more different data
but it's partly that it's partly just
leveraging more and more computing power
i wonder where that's going to go i
don't know that that's sustainable
but i do think that if you want to get a
sense of where this field is going think
a little bit about language in
particular
because
if i go back and think a little bit
about how government agencies were
making decisions in the late 90s when i
was there
most of the expert analysis was being
done using techniques like probit logit
econometrics like regression stuff
you're going to be learning about in
this class but it was being mediated
through humans presenting to each other
what ar systems may increasingly have
the capacity to do is to use those very
same techniques but to then communicate
with the user in a way that is adaptive
to the human
and able to leverage
language in a way that previously
software did not do so that persuasive
ability of software is something we have
never really seen before and as we have
more effective use of compute and
greater use of compute i think the feats
that will be possible when you sort of
marry up the gt3 type stuff with the
analytics will be very different which
is to say a lot of humans who are
consuming the output are not necessarily
going to be in a great position to be
very sophisticated arbiters of whether
what they're being told or recommended
is accurate or not
just to wrap up
there are all kinds of interesting
intersections now about the law and
ai and policy problems that result
i want to make a pitch to you this is
kind of tentative i'm not as certain
about this as i am about other things
that we're actually having this really
weird bifurcated bimodal distribution of
attention to the problems where some
problems now are so familiar
that we don't necessarily know how to
solve them but you will hear the
buzzwords very often explainability
interpretability
bias
privacy
etc and these problems i think of as not
medium to long-term problems they are
present day problems they have hit
already just ask robert williams
and then when you see an interview with
like elon musk
then you're going to hear about
catastrophic or existential risk
i think that it would probably be a big
mistake to ignore catastrophic of
existence or existential risk much as i
would have argued in the 1960s if i'd
been alive then and an adult then
anybody who was interested in the future
of fossil fuels even if we didn't have
all the science
would probably be
making a mistake if they ignored
completely what the risks might be if
they were trying to understand the risk
systemically for the planet
of
the use at scale of these techniques for
producing energy once the rest of the
world meaning poor people in indonesia
india and africa and china began to
demand
the level of consumption of energy that
americans and europeans have taken had
taken for granted right
but i still think that in some ways the
catastrophic or existential risk piece
is not a risk that i believe the world
is likely to be facing
in five years or eight years or ten
years
that's just maybe um something we can go
into in the q a about why that is but i
suspect that the the level of delegation
we have already engaged in the ai
systems doesn't get to the point where
they can
protect their purview and power without
our intervention as well as they might
someday
and obviously that requires for the
thinking but that leaves some seriously
interesting issues that i think really
deserve attention more in the short term
for one
this question of where causal
responsibility lies
when a system that deploys ai
acts in a way that is not safe think
about the autonomous vehicle but not
only the autonomous vehicle think about
the ai system in a large company that
increasingly is making financial
decisions
reviewed by humans perhaps needed by
humans but increasingly in an autonomous
way i think that problems involving
power and collective action are really
interesting in this space so if you're
running a large company and suddenly
27 of those jobs are now going to be
or the functions done by different
people in different jobs are now going
to be done by ai systems how does that
redistribute power within the
organization
how does the advent of lethal autonomous
weapons influence the distribution of
power in geopolitics for example how
does it empower countries with smaller
armies and so on
another point which is familiar to
people working on cars in particular is
that precision can spur disagreement
right now a lot of legal rules are
written in fairly general terms
which is to say
humans are not supposed to drive when
they are impaired they're supposed to
engage in driving that shows reasonable
care etc etc these are fairly vague
descriptions in the court figure out
what that means in particular fact
patterns with the help of a jury
but when you can actually program
an automated system to make split-second
decisions that are extremely precise
about when and how to prioritize
exposing some smaller number of humans
to risk when you can save a larger
number of humans like a variation of a
trolley problem that will spur
disagreements that didn't exist before
just like mapping technologies when they
developed and became more precise
spurred disagreements between different
countries
that previously shared borders in very
inhospitable locations when the border
could really not be
traced with quite as much detail and
specificity
just to mention maybe one or two last
quick things on this slide
i think it's going to be really
interesting as ai systems
pose the question of what it means
to maximize social welfare like how do
you design a system that is going to
have its core attribute this is what you
want to do and some people are trying to
do that it's going to try to keep humans
safe
or it's going to try to avoid doing
anything that will imperil too many
people
taking human values and turning them
into code is actually really really
difficult
and it is related to the process through
which humans think about change and
conflict which is to say
we often deal with conflict or
institutions like courts and
legislatures increasingly as we deal
with conflict or machines we'll have to
program machines to help diffuse
conflict and not only to point out how
two views that seem to be very similar
are actually in tension with each other
all right so we've gotten to my very
last slide i'll end here there's
probably too much text on it but here's
what i want to highlight
if you are listening to this lecture and
you're thinking i hope that part of my
career is spent thinking about how i can
help move ai and the design of ai so
that it is socially beneficial
i want to highlight to you that that is
actually really difficult to define it
probably in ways you've already
anticipated but i want to highlight in
particular a tension between two
different ways of thinking of what the
social good is for purposes of ai and
pretty much everything else
in one version of what it means to work
for the social good you basically
develop systems that increasingly are
good at giving people what they want
what they say they want but especially
what their behavior indicates that they
like and that they value
so the entertainment that they want the
products that they want the classes that
they want the kind of teaching that
maximizes student evaluation you know
feedback and so on
but of course you know part of what
makes life so interesting is that
there's a separation sometimes between
what people say they want
and what they actually want or what
people say they want and what they do or
for that matter what people want at time
one when you started listening to this
lecture and what you want right now it's
probably to stop right and once you
start admitting to the idea that human
welfare is more complicated
and further once you start designing
systems that are in real time shaping
human
affect and culture and behavior it
actually becomes really really difficult
to know where to land like how to take
advantage of the human knowledge you
have to know like how to make humans
better off
i don't know how we solve that problem
but i do know that the things that i do
as a judge and the things that we do in
law schools as lawyers and the things
you do as technical experts are
increasingly merging and i don't think
that we can answer these really tough
questions without acknowledging that our
bodies of knowledge have a border that
is increasingly becoming really blurry
and with that
i'm going to stop and thank you for
listening and i'm looking forward to
your comments and questions and
feedbacks concurring opinions to sense
whatever you want to share
so i think yeah so the way you're going
to go for
questions and thoughts is either raise
your hand or put it on a chat and then
they'll just call you or read the
question great
i should add that if we were in a real
classroom
what law professors do is we call on
people so i would call on people but i
can't really call them people so i'm
going to wait for your questions i have
a question you mentioned that a lot of
the laws right that will be used for ai
actually already exists you can give an
example for an existing law that you
think will be used for ai applications
or systems
pretty soon
absolutely great question thank you
the short answer is let me let me start
with the common law which are the
subjects that we teach
law students in the first year that are
they're sort of defined by the fact that
the law is a little bit more judge-made
so someone like you as you as you
learn
basic civics of a system like the
american system
in most cases the legislature is elected
to enact what the law is and then
the executive branch will implement it
and then the courts will judge and
interpret like what the law means but
there are certain branches of the law
where in our anglo-american tradition
the law is actually first developed by
judges over time little by little case
by case and then the legislature will
jump in and they will tweak the law in
this way that way so so those bodies of
law include
contract law and tort law and both of
those are so clearly about ai at some
level so contract law is the law of
promises that we make to each other and
when they're binding and when they're
not right
when professor saudi promised you a good
class i think she's delivering as
are her colleagues in this class but
like if you say well the class wasn't
good i've been defrauded
you know the law will try to determine
whether there's like a actual legal
claim that you have or not
so in the air context just imagine now
for a moment
that increasingly transactions are being
made by two ai systems making spot
contracts with each other in a split
second because you've pre-programmed one
to say as long as this stock falls below
this price buy a whole bunch of it right
and when the lines of supply and demand
cross because two ai systems are talking
to each other
the deal is made but then it turns out
that maybe this was class c shares of
stock not class a
and so like whose gets who's stuck you
know dealing with the cost of a
transaction that is not what both
parties wanted so existing contract law
has a lot to say about that
now tort law is an area of law that
frankly when i was a law student i
thought was really boring when i was a
law professor i thought was kind of
technically complicated not that
interesting to me i had my hands full of
teaching other stuff as a judge i think
of it as fascinating really really
interesting that's the body of law
governing
when your conduct harms other people and
when you were liable for that
there is no way to have a discussion
about cars like automated cars without
having tort law be a big part of that
so like you know
to what extent is the
designer of the software that runs the
vision system for the car responsible
for this person who gets run over versus
the person who runs the company that
tested the software versus the company
that designed the car and marketed for
you versus the driver that pushed the
car to operate in really bad weather and
and torque is really complicated but i
will just give you one quick insight
which is very intuitive which is
one workforce concept in tort law which
has been on the books for a while
is the notion that the tortella should
pay attention other things being equal
to who in that chain of causation is in
the best position to have avoided the
harm at the lowest cost least cost
avoidable and you can see how here that
would be a really interesting and
important question like who could have
done a very little bit to avoid that
person from getting run over there are
dozens of other areas of law but this to
me is a really good example of how when
silicon valley says like oh we have to
decide if ai is going to be regulated
i think there's a little disconnect with
reality
okay i think we have
go ahead yeah
yeah thanks i have a question so um
these systems are probably like very
opaque for judges and people who
actually have to make decisions about
you know what happened and how does it
interact with case law and statutes and
whatever and my question is if as a
judge you have to answer a question of
fact about a particular ai system
you just like have experts come in and
testify and be like well nobody else has
any hope of being able to understand it
so we're just going to take what they
say as gospel or do like judges and
clerks and things like actually try to
educate themselves on math behind how
the stuff works
that is an excellent question and i have
good news and bad news what do you want
to hear first
uh let's let's hear the good news
okay
the good news is that in some ways the
problem you've just described is not
completely new to law
and in our system we have a kind of
interplay of
decision making that involves
jurors being
asked
subject to some instructions given by
judges how to interpret an ambiguous
fact pattern lay people who are supposed
to be acting in their best
conscientious effort to do the right
thing and follow the instructions and
then
experts who in an adversarial system are
selected carefully vetted carefully
debriefed before they sort of come
before the court and then subject to
cross-examination who can shed light on
things and help the jurors and the judge
make decisions and then judges who are
supposed to resolve questions as a
matter of law like questions that
ultimately are more about how to
interpret the legal issue itself
and if for example a statute says
a quote-unquote highly autonomous system
shall be regulated subject to subpart j
but then like is this a highly
autonomous system or not so that's a
mixed question of law in fact for
example the judge might do part of it so
in particular the expert testimony piece
will frequently involve experts who come
and pick at the really intricate like
math type questions that you're raising
and i wouldn't say the system is perfect
but i would say the system works okay so
other contexts where the highly
technical
gets adjudicated kind of like it would
in an ai context would be dna evidence
for example
base pairs and you know what does it
mean if you say
the match is 1 in
1.7 billion how do you know that what's
the difference between
1 and 1 3 and 3 million which is what
the other experts said like we have a
way of dealing with elections
here is the bad news though
i think the bad news is that none of the
technologies in the past
have had the potential that ai systems
do
to talk back and i think that is like
not a small thing because what that
means is
these ai systems can be designed in a
way that i think creates a little bit of
a comforting illusion
that even the experts understand what's
really going on when they may be
influenced more by
design choices that might be really
really hard to arbiter
where
the ai system is actually
maximizing not
the level of accuracy it conveys to the
user about the mathematical basis for a
conclusion like that this person is
likely to reoffend
but instead
maximizing the possibility that the
decision maker who's being influenced by
the ai system is going to agree with it
and that could even be an expert who's
testifying right so this is where
ai accountability begins to merge with
cyber security with me like ultimately
like cyber security problems are very
much about how like if you go back
literally to supply chains and how you
can mess up
the very core architecture of how like a
microprocessor works the ways you can
bias results that can become incredibly
difficult even for an expert to pick a
part and i don't think we have a great
answer for that like there may be
blockchain type like really fancy ways
of of using like
you know hardcore like
encryption like stuff to sort of like
have greater
confidence in results and to know when
things have been messed with
but somewhere along the line there are
humans and humans are imperfect and i
just i worry about that piece of it a
lot
awesome and
uh we have a couple of questions in the
chat
uh are you able to view the chat
uh let's see i see three participants
raised hand that's oh
[Music]
do you want to take both of them
together
yes let me see from a global perspective
any collaboration between countries
regard of ai adoption you see ai systems
from countries with different values
will be prevented from being adopted
okay and then similar to how developing
countries will strive to attain
the same level of life quality as
developed countries it seems just a
matter of time before ai becomes the
next thing
how should we think about international
cooperational rivalry oh yes in ai
development is there anything we can do
as technologists to help how should we
navigate a time where u.s
has marked ai software export
restrictions okay great questions
let me start with the second one a
little bit so
i think that
as technologists you can probably help
by
trying to make sure that the hype
doesn't run away with the discussion of
these issues
so i could find people
who are in the national security world i
can find people who are in the public
intellectual world
who will see the relationship between
the us and other countries
so much through the lens of rivalry
that very little space will be left
for any collaboration between scientists
for example between
civil society nonprofits that are trying
to reduce the risk of climate change by
using machine learning tools or whatever
and i think that technologists will be
important voices in saying
we can be legitimately concerned about
how differences in technological
development can affect geopolitics or
relations between different countries
but not run to the conclusion that
everything is pure competition
i bet you that there are people in this
class who are not born in the u.s well i
know that's the case because i wasn't
born in the u.s and i know that's true
of others of you and to me that's like a
really poignant reminder of the risks of
having the conversation about eye shut
down to the point that it becomes too
one-sided and too
too much just about national advancement
in no way do i want to deny
and this will get me a little into this
first to the earlier question
that there were different agendas
different goals different
geopolitical objectives of different
countries and that getting some
advantage in ai technology can translate
into potential military
and economic advantage so some balance
has to be struck and that requires some
careful discussion it requires some
norms it requires some cooperation from
universities because we think of
universities as working best when mostly
things are pretty open in the university
we share knowledge i learn from you all
you will learn from me etc
but the reality is sometimes careful
languages have to be drawn
and ultimately that does reflect the
reality that countries do have different
values about others and i'll just
mention one word that it is a simple way
of making that point but there are other
examples i could give you
the word is privacy
so i can imagine many countries in the
world that could argue either
that their populations simply have no
particular reason to value privacy the
way americans do or
that whether their population values
privacy or not their law is such that
they prioritize other things and they're
simply going to gather a ton of data
about a ton of stuff
and
i don't think that data translates
automatically to greater power in the ai
space but it is a significant advantage
if you have it like it'll be interesting
to ask in the coming months and years to
what extent some combination of
reinforcement learning and the
generation of artificial sort of fake
data
like or fake you know information inputs
into like a reinforcement learning
algorithm can make up for just raw
access to real world data but i still
think a corpus of actual human behavior
is quite something and if you simply
didn't have to worry about privacy
the insights you might get into the
expressions on people's faces when
they're having a private conversation
about something incredibly sensitive or
the fear you can see in somebody's eyes
when they begin to realize that they've
said something
on social media that is likely to bring
a knock on the door from the police
is valuable particularly if your goal is
to try to not only
not only improve the lot and the
well-being of the population but to
control them and to limit the extent to
which they push against you so i think
this leaves us in a really challenging
space like i really really would urge
all of us
to highlight the importance of some
public collaboration across borders on
this
we don't stand much of a chance i think
of getting really to where humanity
needs to get to on so many crucial
issues including ai safety by the way we
don't have some sharing of information
pure competition is going to drive a lot
of the dangerous and riskiest
technological experimentation on the
ground at least for a while
on the other hand i think we'd be naive
to think that everybody shares interests
so
some degree of building of norms and
cooperation among communities of people
who are in civil society in the world of
nonprofits or philanthropy or education
i think will be really crucial
as a
question yes
the general question this
comes to be real
if i just say i've developed projects
and i have to connect all the
information from the network
uh
so what should i
share or take care of
something like the copyright
privacy
and the commission from the source
society or even some citation i have to
prepare
this kind of thing
yeah yeah thank you i this is a really
big subject let me just try to abstract
a little bit from your good question
you're basically
raising the broader question of how we
might think of ownership and
responsibility over data particularly as
people work together on these projects
that mine huge amounts of data
and use it in maybe different ways i
mean
i and i'll give you a short answer but
then i'll elaborate a little bit the
short answer is increasingly the world
is waking up to the fact that control
over data really is control over
property in some ways so just as you
might have a
use agreement that says to somebody you
can you can license the use of this
technology that i've developed let's say
a piece of hardware like a camera that
can
see really really well at night but by
using this camera you are
agreeing not to use it to uh you know
look into people's homes without the
permission or something so increasingly
i would say there is a criss-crossing
regime of law some of it is state law
some of it is federal law pertaining to
particular classes of data like medical
data that really highly regulates the
use of data
by the same token are there
opportunities still to harvest scrape
even data from say the public internet
that can then be used in different ways
well of course and sometimes
that will allow breakthroughs to occur
in ai
but but this is where it gets really
tricky because we're really in the midst
now of developing
national and then eventually maybe
global norms about what it means to
appropriately design ai systems that
will get rid of data that no longer are
needed for the original purpose so let
me give you two competing perspectives
about that first one is that because ai
systems are so capable of developing
insights using the techniques you are
learning in this class
that discern patterns in the data that
human intuition would not have been able
to detect
big masses of data used in new ways is
risky because it means that maybe you
end up getting embarrassed about people
discovering that
the fact that you like a certain kind of
literature and that your eyes move in a
certain way when you're in a
conversation mean that you have a really
short attention span and you can't be
trusted with a certain kind of job right
so those questions are partly being
mediated with the respect to like do we
not create norms that once data are used
for the purpose for which they are
collected we destroy the data
now i'll give you the perspective of me
the academic
so a lot of my early work as a law
professor was historical i would
actually look at
old
memos and documents that were going back
to like presidential decisions made like
in the roosevelt administration where i
was looking at what happened when
roseville was trying to reorganize the
government on the eve of world war ii
and how he was trying to protect certain
programs from being defunded as the
country was getting ready to go to war
by the way as a little subplot on that
one of the things i learned about that i
was not expecting is that there was a
big biological weapons research program
that was being funded with white house
support despite the fact that that
arguably contravened certainly contrary
statements the white house had made and
arguably contravened you know certain
aspects of legal norms at the time but
long story short the point is
if the norm had been followed that you
only keep the data for its original
intended use and then get rid of it
where in the world would i be able to
write the stuff that i did how would i
be able to do it and you could say okay
well those are presidential records
that's different but in general the
historians who write about how humans
lived 150 years ago are doing it with
data that were not intended for
historians
so i think we have to strike a balance
but i would say you should assume
whenever you're dealing with data that
there's probably some rule and if there
isn't some rule that's in the law it's
probably in human subjects requirements
in a universal
yeah and my question is with regards to
the out of lab and the in the models
working inside the lab which you
mentioned
so and uh so let's say if uh an
organization develops a model let's say
it's for an auto
self-driving cars for example i'm just
picking it up
99 of the time
it inside the lab the models work very
well
and outside the lab you know it causes
uh loss of a person a life
is an example i'm taking an extreme here
so if this kind of situation comes to
you as a judge in your code
what is the decision making
which on the law side which you take
with regards to the ai model and what's
the
thinking which goes behind you
to make this kind of
the judgment against
the maker of the model or so it's
working 99
of the time but there are failures
because you know the models are
true uh given what has been coded and
what the training has been it has been
done on so i'm just wondering the
decision process what would uh
so is it tied to the risk or which the
company has
done the due diligence
or
what is the essence of
the responsibility and
so that was the broad questions thank
you
thank you so
that's a another good opportunity for me
to share with you how much existing law
is already grappling with these issues
that arise that are so relevant to ai
and particularly to the scaling up of ai
outside the laboratory
so i'll preface this by saying that
because i'm a sitting judge i wouldn't
want you to feel like i'm telling you
exactly how i would decide the case if
it came up because we actually have
cases that are not like what you're
saying that are pending in the
california courts and i'm not supposed
to say how decide them but i can tell
you
i can tell you in general the bodies of
law that are relevant to trying to deal
with this question
and in what direction they've moved over
time
so
we have bodies of law particularly in
tort law and in contract law
and in consumer protection law more
generally that can use basically three
sorts of techniques to deal with the
risk that you're pointing to which
arises when you go from
highly efficacious behavior in the lab
to what happens when
some technology is operating quote
unquote in the real world so when a
vision system for example is tested in
control conditions it works fine but now
you're putting it on the front end of a
car that is going to work mostly
autonomously and it's driving around
palo alto and then even driving around
some much more irregular environment
like
some dusty road unpaved in northern
mexico
so one body of law is tort law again
this is the body of law involving
the duties that you owe for example to
others as a company or as a person and
here
a core insight of tort lies that you
have a
duty of care if there's a theory of
negligence that is being or well let me
put it this way
if the claim is that the manufacturer
should have been more careful than the
manufacturer was and the manufacturer
owes a duty to the person who's using
the product which is its own separate
question
a crucial
issue will be
the extent to which prevailing norms in
the industry about how much testing
happens outside the lab or followed or
not
the more those norms converge
the easier it is for the company to say
perhaps like well look we did some
outside the lab testing
you know you could easily spend a
billion dollars a day testing outside
the lab infinitely but we did enough
testing that we met the industry not
a different technique would be to rely
more on contract law where you could say
i was sold a product that was guaranteed
to me to have a degree of safety and
efficacy in it and in fact it didn't
reflect that
because it wasn't tested outside the lab
and the promise that was made to me was
not that this product was just tested in
the lab it also implied a lot of testing
outside the lab
and the third strategy is more
administrative regulation
so this is like what the fda does with
respect to pharmaceutical products and
here the key insight
is that we don't rely purely just on
tort law or contract law we actually
have the government saying to you you
can only sell this product if you've
tested it in a particular way and as you
go through that pharmaceutical approval
process and get into phase two phase
three phase four trials effectively what
you're doing is you're going further and
further outside the lab
so we can do this to some degree they're
going to be some nuances but i think
it's really important to remember we
have different tools we can use to deal
with that risk
thank you
notice we have a couple of questions on
the chat so we do some of those and then
come back to the raised hands yes i
think maybe we have time just to take uh
uh these two
are you guys these two questions so
first
on the criminal justice system
oh i see that okay i'm going to just
read it out if we find that an algorithm
deployed in the criminal justice system
that doesn't explicitly take into
account race but it's systematically
discriminated against black people
perhaps compass
are the your legal ways to counter that
discrimination is it constitutional they
can do a count to protect a character
like race oh great okay doesn't mean we
uh just shouldn't use the algorithm oh
okay excellent question
so the short answer is the legal system
has in america for good reason
been long
deeply concerned with racial inequities
whether it has
been sufficiently concerned is a
question that we can leave for another
day and others can talk about but
it has been concerned about it and that
concern is reflected in several parts of
our legal system it's reflected in a lot
of statutes at the state and federal
level against discrimination by race
like
provisions against discrimination and
employment and hiring
but it's also reflected in the
constitution for example in the equal
protection clause of the constitution
and here i would just say
the legal system treats differently uses
of race that are well first of all the
legal system treats different uses of
race than other classifications that
people might be subjected to
they are subjected to
what the legal system calls strict
scrutiny which is a very very demanding
form of review where they're essentially
explicit
classifications are not permitted unless
there's a very
compelling strong justification on the
part of the government and there's no
really no realistic way of doing it in a
different manner
where it gets more complicated with
something like compass is where there's
no explicit racial classification and
you still have biases and here i just
note that you can
find algorithmic ways
to reduce that bias or even disappear it
completely
and there might even be legal reasons to
do that but
generally when you do that one of two
trade-offs will happen you will either
increase the likelihood that other
variables that may not otherwise be so
consequential become more consequential
so to some people that might mean you're
introducing a certain kind of different
bias although we may not care about it
as much because it may not be racial
or you simply reduce the accuracy of the
overall model in some cases now
that may be entirely sensible to do
but these questions about when and how
you recalibrate the results of a
decision-making process because it
doesn't take race into account and yet
it still
gives unequal results is a very familiar
and vexing and difficult question in
criminal justice and in the legal system
more generally let me just take the last
question then
which one is it the one that says via
advertising complicated
question actually
okay so my question is regarding is that
one how much tolerance okay would citing
have when ai makes mistakes on the one
hand we say humans are not perfect on
the other hand we want to see how much a
company can improve an algorithm to
avoid an accident caused by their ai
powered product to what extent should
they our product manufacturers optimize
their product to become acceptable
great question
i think this gives us a chance to end
where we began actually because when it
started i highlighted to you that
not only can ai have many benefits for
society
i named some but also that the relevant
comparison is not to perfection but to
what imperfect forms of decision making
we might have to rely on if we don't
rely on a particular ai system
but
it would be wrong to conclude from that
discussion
that as long as ai systems are more
accurate than human decision makers then
there's no legal problem or there's no
policy problem i think instead the
reality is
that as ai performance improves in a
very discreet domain
two things might happen
the first that are relevant to the
answer to your question the first is
that we may come to understand and trust
ai systems better to make that discrete
decision
so long as it doesn't introduce some
other biases that we think of as even
more concerning
so
notice the point that i made about
how ai systems
might be really good at picking out
faces that are unfamiliar relative to
humans who are picking out unfamiliar
faces
but if they're trying to discern emotion
they may not be as good as humans right
now that might change over time but
right now that means that we have to be
very specific with respect to what we're
expecting system to do rather than
presuming that there's a sort of halo
efficacy beyond the very narrow context
in which it's been tested
which might have to include just beyond
the lab right
number two as ai systems get better in
general
the standard of care that the legal
system uses to discern whether something
works effectively or not will begin to
be redefined so that it's not just human
efficacy it's a well-performing ai
systems efficacy and not only a
well-performing a system but ideally a
well-performing ai system that does not
have a built-in set of biases that we
consider problematic so that means for
example
if over time 70
of human passengers were in autonomous
vehicles rather than human driven ones
been a faulty form of performance from
one of those vehicles that increases the
risk of
harm and actually results in somebody
getting harmed
might still be actionable
despite the fact that even that faulty
system works a lot better than human
drivers did
it also means that even if ai systems
are better at discerning new faces
if their accuracy is much much better
for white faces than black faces
that would be a policy and potentially
legal problem for some
that might require remediation and
attention even if the system works
better than humans
all of which is why i think these
problems are going to keep your
generation busy for a long time
thank you all right
thank you so much you know thanks for
the great talk and awesome discussion
and there are lots of interesting
questions this is really fun
uh so let's thank you know again
thank you everybody i really enjoyed
this and i appreciate your very
thoughtful questions and best of luck
you